après tout une nouvelle maman pédagogie
c'est peut être enlevé sur les rythmes
scolaires comment innover dans les
politiques publiques de l'éducation
l'une des questions posées durant cette
première soirée du comité de soutien de
saint germain en laye à l'action du
président de la république une
cinquantaine de personnes ont participé
à cet atelier autour de l'éducation
j'aime bien le format c'est très très
intéressant de faire travailler les gens
ensemble et puis faire émerger des idées
je trouve ça très intéressant pouvoir
échanger avec des gens qui semble
passionner par l'éducation en plus on a
à la fois des parents des professeurs
des gens intéressés par le sujet des
fils d'enseignant en voilà c'était a
vraiment un panel très varié ces comités
de soutien à l'action du président de la
république une initiative nationale mise
en place à saint germain en laye par le
maire arnaud péricard pour porter la
potentielle future candidature d'
emmanuel macron je pense nos citoyens
ont des choses à dire ils ne sont
peut-être plus membre d'un parti ou
d'une association politique mais ils ont
des choses à dire et donc l'objectif
notamment de cette réunion c'est de
capter voilà de capter cette
intelligence collective de capter ces
idées pendant 30 minutes les
participants ont été changées sur quatre
thématiques avant cela un rappel a été
fait sur les mesures mises en place
durant le quinquennat avec notamment le
dédoublement des classes de cp et ce1 en
zone d'éducation prioritaire je crois
que c'est emblématique et puis moi pour
avoir visité pas mal de classes de
petite classe comme ça on voit qu'à
douze élèves il ya vraiment un niveau de
calme et que les élèves travaillent par
petits groupes d'une façon complètement
différente et dans de bien meilleures
conditions objectifs de ces ateliers
nourrir le futur programme du président
sortant prochaine thématique traitée à
saint-germain-en-laye l'économie le 15
décembre 2021